- Do you have any big plans
for Christmas this year?
- Well, I'm going back to the
East Coast where my family is.
I'm hoping for some snow
which would be really cool.
It's a little weird to be in
California during the holidays.
It's a little strange.
- I know. I'm not here either.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm actually gonna be East Coast this-
- Are you?
- Yeah, yeah.
I love it. All snowy and stuff, yeah.
- Me too. I hope we get some.
- You're from somewhere magical
though, is it Burlington?
- I'm from Burlington, Massachusetts.
- I've heard about Burlington,
that it's like magical at Christmas time.
- You did?
- I'm not kidding.
I literally, I Google all the time
like, where's magical places
to go at Christmas time?
And I swear to you, that comes up.
- From Burlington, Massachusetts?
- I swear to you, it's that-
- You sure it isn't Vermont?
- There's a place in Vermont.
And there's this random
place in Washington.
I swear, I Google random things.
But Burlington has come up.
It's a very beautiful
small town.
- I'm actually going back.
My brother lives in Sweden.
His family is coming in
and we're all going back
to my childhood home to
spend Christmas together,
which is awesome.
- That's cool.
- Yeah. Really cool.
And it's been a long time
since we've all been in the same house.
And all the grandkids
are gonna stay there.
And we all have, you
know, like inflatable beds
and everyone's sleeping in the basement.
Really fun. It's gonna be so fun.
- My kids, it's so funny
you just said that.
My daughter was like,
"Mom, okay, so I went
to my friend Leah's house
and, like, she had this really cool thing.
They like blew it up and then
it was in their living room.
We got to sleep in their living room."
And I'm like, "I love that, like,
I work my butt off to provide you with
the most amazing room possible.
The most comfy mattress.
And yet still you want my childhood
of a blow up mattress from Walmart."
- 100%. That's all they want.
- They do. They love it.
And I love that vibe though.
Like, there's so many people in the house.
So I love that.
I think that's cool.
- Yes, nobody in, nobody out.
That's what we say. (laughs)
- It's prison. It's forced family fun.
It's a good time.
Is there anything that annoys
you about the holiday time?
- Ooh, well I think that,
you know what I think is so cool now is
that everybody celebrates
it their own way.
And I kind of feel,
you know what annoys me, is
when people don't stop working
actually.
- Oh.
- Like, I feel like when people assume
that you're gonna be
available all the time.
You need to chill.
If this young generation has
taught us anything, it's like,
take a minute, allow yourself a day off.
Whatever it is.
- This generation is like
a walking Calm app.
Yeah, they're really great about it.
- They're like, work smarter, not harder.
Productivity is a myth
that you've been sold.
And we're like, no? Okay, yes.
- Do you usually have a cutoff date? I do.
Where I'm like I will
not do anything past,
it's either when "The Voice" ends,
that last day, the finale, I'm like, nope.
- Same. We all have the same
"Voice" cutoff. (laughs)
- No, well, it's either
like, whatever show I'm doing
or this show, like we're done.
Like this year it's
the 16th of December is
my first day out and I
will not work after it.
So just so you know, everyone out there,
I'm not doing anything.
- That's really good.
Yeah, no email.
You have to like actually unplug.
You have to unplug.
So when people don't
do that, it stresses me
out a little bit, also because
I feel like I should be,
it's, you know-
- Yeah, don't make me feel bad
'cause you're still doing it.
- Don't make me feel bad.
- Don't shame me 'cause I
need some time.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay, so wait. You cook.
I know you're crafty.
So is there any one skill,
you're crafty.
So you do all those kind of things.
So is there any one skill
that you wish you had
that you don't have?
- Oh, so many.
I mean, singing. I wish I
could play an instrument.
You know what?
I wish I could just go
into someone's house
at a party and be like, "Where
did you get this piano?"
Like, that would be my dream.
- That's mine.
- You cannot play the piano?
- I can play chords and, like,
write a song.
- Oh, only chords?
- No, no, no, no. Ask Jason.
- All you need is a little tinkle, like,
just like ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
And then someone comes over and goes,
"What are you playing?"
Like, that's my dream.
- Yeah.
- And I'd also like,
I guess like rescuing someone
in front of a lot of people.
That's what I would like to do.
- Okay.
You wanna be admired for being a hero?
- Yeah, just jumping in the
water and pulling someone
out and being like, "That's
just another day at work."
And then you just get on the piano
and you just play a song that you-
- You do all of them combined.
Oh, that house? I just built that.
- And then you just jump
on your speedboat and you-
- We need this ad (laughs)
to go with this segment.
- Wow, you're really
stumping me with skills.
I know there's so many
of I would love to do.
- I love that that answer though
because I feel like that's when
you really, like, are jaded.
I feel like I love to keep learning.
I love to learn new things.
- Me too.
- I think it's fun.
- Even if I'm not great at it.
- I know and it's kind
of hard 'cause you're,
like, there's science behind it.
Like your brain as it gets older gets,
it gets harder to learn new things,
but it's what you're supposed to
do to keep your brain elastic.
You know, you're supposed
to wear your watch
on the other side of your wrist
and you're supposed to brush
with the different hand just
to keep your brain moving.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah. Do it tonight.
- Oh my god, it's gonna feel
so weird with my left hand.
- It'll feel so weird.
And your brain grows
five times, I don't know.
- I am ADHD though, so
I probably naturally do
a lot of these things.
- Yeah, you probably do it anyway.
- [Kelly] I'm like very weird.